When it comes to performance, there are some things you can control,
There are other things you just have to be aware of and circumvent.
My name is Colt McCannless.
CPU redundancy is one of those hard facts
For mobile phone development
Which you can not control, but can have a big impact on your application.
Atri, in order to keep the battery,
Android devices can reduce the amount of power in the CPU.
This means that the processor will consume less power to execute the code,
With the side effect of the CPU slowdown in the process.
Basically, the code will take longer to work.
This is a very normal event.
The Android device constantly tries to reduce the incoming power supply of the CPU
To provide as much energy as possible.
The interactive CPU organizer used by Android
The workload is constantly checked on the CPU to determine
The possibility of reducing the frequency or if it needs to raise its value.
The implications of such things are a little strange to you as a developer.
First, when the frequency value is reduced,
You'll notice that normal operations take longer to complete.
So do not be surprised if suddenly,
The time frame increases have begun to exceed 16 milliseconds.
Second, frequency changes take about 20 milliseconds to occur,
Which means that if you are going out of low frequency mode,
The first submission window may be slower
Given the fact that the CPU has not been able to increase yet.
In general, you have to remember that this works deliberately.
The battery is the most important thing in mobile phone development.
For the Android system, it does a really good job
From balancing processing speed versus battery consumption for you,
So you do not have to worry about it.
In fact, there is a whole range of things
By Android to avoid this problem when the performance is very important,
Such as increasing frequency quickly once the user touches the screen.
But other times, such as if you use a service or respond to an event,
You can see these issues express themselves.
Just keep in mind that if you start to notice a rise in frame rate
Or that orders take too long without a reason,
The use of measuring frequency can be the culprit.
To confirm this, you can run the Systrace feature, enabling the CPU frequency tag.
You will notice a nice band at the top that separates current frequency values,
So you can see the overall effect on your performance.
Performance is built around understanding what hardware devices are doing
And how your code should react accordingly.
In this case, you can not do much.
But in all other cases, there are a lot of things you can work on.
So be sure to check out the rest of Android's performance patterns
And do not forget to join the Google+ community for other great tips and tricks.
So stay calm, type your code, and always remember, performance is important.